was hier passiert zieht enorm viel Strom
Papier produzieren ist eine
energieintensives Geschäft ein Geschäft
das sich in Deutschland gerade nicht
rechnet wer woanders produzieren kann
flieht die ganze Branche warnt Form
Standort sterben
in der Papierindustrie sind bereits
einige Schließungen angekündigt wir
gehen davon aus dass auch große moderne
Standorte
teilweise schon in diesem Jahr aber auch
in den nächsten Jahren verschwinden
werden andere Branchen berichten das
gleiche die Chemieindustrie etwa
prophezeit einen Produktionsrückgang von
8% in diesem Jahr im Mai erklärt der
Wirtschaftsminister was er zur Rettung
Unternehmen will ein industriestrompreis
bis 2030 soll etwa zweieinhalb tausend
Unternehmen Stützen mit einer Deckung
des Strompreises bei 6 Cent pro
Kilowattstunde bis zu 30 Milliarden Euro
soll das Kosten und habe Weg drängt
wenn wir noch lange hier herum
diskutieren dann ist es auch fast egal
was wir entscheiden weil dann die
Investitionsentscheidung oder eben nicht
getroffen sind der Kanzler aber ist von
havix Plan nicht überzeugt Scholz müsste
diese stromsubvention von der EU
genehmigen lassen Scholz müsste wissen
woher das Geld kommen soll und Scholz
müsste die FDP brüskieren die
habichtskonzept komplett ablehnt muss
Herr Habeck dann seine Idee beerdigen
also ich bin es genauso wie der
Bundeskanzler der ja auch sehr sehr
skeptisch ist ja wir müssen über den
Strompreis reden wir müssen über ein
erweitertes Angebot reden wir müssen
über Entlastung bei der Steuer reden
aber nur über eine kurze Subvention zu
sprechen die dann ja eher ein Strohfeuer
ist wie der Bundeskanzler zu Recht sagt
das macht keinen Sinn
die FDP fürchtet eine teure
sinnlos-aktion die Bundesländer fürchten
dass ihre Industrie eingeht in dieser
Woche bitten die 16 länderchefinnen und
Chefs um den Segen der EU-Kommission für
einen deutschen industriestrompreis und
erhöhen den Druck auf den Kanzler
ich unterstelle immer viel Vernunft in
der Politik eigentlich kann ich mir
nicht vorstellen dass die Bundespolitik
zusieht dass tatsächlich eine solche
Entwicklung einkehrt an deren Ende viele
Branchen in Deutschland wahrscheinlich
so nicht mehr existieren würden es ist
große Unsicherheit da weil der
Finanzminister das Gegenteil von
Wirtschaftsminister erzählt wir brauchen
dringend eine Entscheidung wir brauchen
Klarheit Planungssicherheit für die
Unternehmen
eine Schwäche von habex
industriestrompreis zeigt sich in
Unternehmen wie diesem hier auch backen
ist energieintensiv auch hier leiden sie
unter den Strompreisen wenn jetzt die
großen buggiganten gestützt würden
fürchten die kleinen dass sie dafür
bluten müssen
es geht darum diese Verzerrung zu
verhindern weil wir als
Handwerksunternehmen können Deutschland
nicht verlassen die Konsequenz daraus
wäre das Unternehmen letztendlich im
Handwerksbereich schließen wenn Sie
diesen Wettbewerb nicht verstehen
dementsprechend Arbeitsplätze verlieren
wir und dementsprechend auch
Ausbildungsplätze würden verloren der
hohe Strompreis in Deutschland liegt
auch an einem komplizierten Geflecht von
Steuern Abgaben und Umlagen hier setzt
ein Gegenvorschlag zum
industriestrompreis an senken für alle
das würde den besonders Energie
intensiven Unternehmen deutlich weniger
helfen als sein eigener Preis dafür
beugt es Marktverzerrungen vor
man könnte die Stromsteuer auf das
europäische Minimum senken man könnte
bei den Abgaben und Umlagen tatsächlich
noch reduzieren und dadurch wirklich
alle entlasten und man hat natürlich
auch selber die hohen Strompreise im
gewissen Umfang verursacht weil man die
Kernkraftwerke abgeschaltet hat also
insgesamt könnte der Staat bei den
Abgaben und Umlagen noch was tun und bei
der Reduktion der Stromsteuer und das
wäre jetzt auch das richtige Mittel
Lindner gegen Harbeck SPD-Kanzler gegen
SPD Ministerpräsidenten und SPD-Fraktion
Großindustrie gegen Mittelstand der
Kampf um die richtige stromstrategie
wird auf verschiedenen Ebenen geführt
und hat das Zeug zum nächsten
eskalierenden ampelkrach
alle 16 Bundesländer haben sich gerade
geschlossen für einen befristeten
brückenstrompreis zugunsten
energieintensiver Firmen ausgesprochen
eine der beteiligten Regierungschefin
ist Anke Rehlinger die SPD
Ministerpräsidentin des Saarlandes die
uns jetzt zugeschaltet ist guten Tag
Frau Rehlinger schönen guten Tag wir
erreichen sie ganz in der Nähe der
Dillinger Hütte den größten grob
blechwerk Europas und einem der
besonders energieintensiven Unternehmen
des Landes wir haben es gerade gesehen
Firmen auch im Saarland drohen zu
schließen oder Richtung billigeren
Stroms abzuwandern wie ernst ist die
Lage
die Unternehmen denen ich rede die haben
ganz klares Signal an die Politik sie
brauchen bezahlbaren bestenfalls ein
erneuerbaren Strom und für den
erneuerbaren Strom müssen wir uns jetzt
einsetzen mit einem massiven Ausbau aber
für die Brücke dass er eben bis dahin
bezahlbar bleibt dafür brauchen wir
jetzt auch ein starkes Signal das haben
die 16 Regierungschefin und Chefs
gegeben sowohl nach Brüssel als auch
nach Berlin und wir brauchen darauf
jetzt wirklich eine schnelle Antwort bei
vielen Firmen stehen ja im Herbst
Investitionsentscheidungen an die Ampel
aber diskutiert ja seit Monaten ohne
Einigung und ihr eigener SPD-Kanzler
lässt sie hängen was spricht denn
beispielsweise gegen eine Senkung der
Stromsteuer für alle wie es eben auch
die FDP vorschlägt ich denke wir müssen
noch mal gucken wer wirklich miteinander
im Wettbewerb steht die deutsche
Stahlindustrie die steht im
internationalen Wettbewerb und den muss
sie bestehen denn wir wollen sie ja zum
Beispiel gerade jetzt umbauen hin zu
grünem Stahl denn das nicht zu tun das
hilft nicht dem Klima sondern hilft
vielleicht allen
China und deshalb sollten wir auch nicht
die Industrie gegen den Mittelstand
ausspielen ich glaube nicht daran dass
es den Mittelstand irgendwie besser geht
wenn erstmal die Industrie verschwunden
ist deshalb muss man jetzt dort Signale
setzen wo sie am notwendigsten sind das
ist bei den Industrien die im
internationalen Wettbewerb stehen dort
geht es um Tausende von Arbeitsplätze
sie zu halten aber eben auch in den
neuen Branchen in denen wir erfolgreich
sein wollen anzusiedeln wie z.B auch in
der Halbleiterproduktion in der
batteriezellfertigung auch da wird
erneuerbarer günstiger
wettbewerbsfähiger Strom gebraucht also
eine
stromsteuersenkung lehnen sie ab
wir müssen gucken dass in dem Maße
geholfen wird wie es gebraucht wird die
stromsteuersenkung ist sicherlich auch
ein spannendes Instrument aber den
energieintensiven Industrien hilft sie
eben nicht in dem Maße wie Sie es
brauchen und deshalb sollten wir nicht
mit weißer Salbe arbeiten sondern wir
sollten das tun was notwendig ist und
das ist jetzt ein klares Signal das ist
Planungssicherheit für die Industrie
dass die Investitionen die sie hier
tätigen wollen auch solche sind die am
Ende darf zu führen dass man Geld
verdienen kann und damit Arbeitsplätze
erhält und neue schafft denn das ist das
wichtigste Ziel nicht nur die Wirtschaft
sondern auch für unseren
gesellschaftlichen Zusammenhalt der
Kanzler ist ja skeptisch unter anderem
mit Blick auf die Kosten und auch ob man
die Subventionen in der EU überhaupt
durchbekommt der hat ja noch nicht
einmal den notwendigen Antrag gestellt
das heißt das Kanzleramt Bastler
stattdessen einer anderen Lösung sehen
auch sie alternative Möglichkeiten der
Industrie zu helfen
ich bin auf jeden Fall immer offen wenn
es andere gleich hilfreiche Lösungen
gibt und ich weiß auch vom Kanzler dass
er genau diese Probleme auch sieht und
er hat natürlich deutlich und zu Recht
auch gesagt es geht nicht um eine Dauer
Subvention das will niemand und dir
besser wie auch beim Ausbau der
erneuerbaren Energien Vorankommen desto
kürzer ist die Brücke die wir
letztendlich auch bauen müssen aber
wichtig ist dass wir zu einer
Entscheidung kommen und ich gehe fest
davon aus Olaf Scholz weiß das genau und
es ist ihm vielleicht auch ein bisschen
zu eigen er redet nicht so viel aber am
Ende kommen damit Lösungen um die Ecke
wann soll die Entscheidung kommen wann
rechnen Sie damit
ich würde mir sehr wünschen dass das
sehr sehr schnell geht das wissen auch
im Grunde genommen alle Beteiligten denn
wir haben es ja mit Angeboten in der
Welt zu tun aus den USA aus dem
asiatischen Raum wo die Strompreise viel
viel niedriger sind und wir wollen ja am
Transformationsprozess Weiterkommen
deshalb brauchen die Unternehmen das
jetzt ich würde es mir so schnell wie
möglich Wünschen der Herbst bis zum Ende
des Jahres spätestens brauchen wir diese
Signale damit wenigstens
Planungssicherheit besteht in welche
Richtung ist hier geht in unserem Land
Frau Ministerpräsidentin herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch
vielen Dank